Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my star wars obi-wan kenobi teaser trailer
and breakdown of the footage that they showed
off the disney investor meeting there was a
bunch of footage that they didn't allow to be
online i'll explain what that is because it
gives you a much better idea of what's happening
during the series and what the plot actually is
alternate title hello there a star wars story
if you're new to the channel of course i'll be
doing videos for all the new star wars disney plus
series that they announced there was a bunch of
new marvel series they announced too that i've
been talking about in my marvel trailer videos
there's 10 new star wars series that they're
developing for disney plus in 10 new marvel series
so it is going to be amazing for the next couple
of years but probably the biggest news out of this
is that they're bringing back hayden christensen
as darth vader so they are going to have a rematch
i'll explain how that's going to work because they
did show off some scenes during the actual panel
footage that weren't allowed online that kind of
explained what their relationship is during the
series because as they say this takes place 10
years after revenge of the sith which is about
nine years before a new hope and if you've been a
star wars fan for a long time following the canon
the expanded material you know that obi-wan kenobi
and darth vader didn't have another rematch after
mustafar until they were on the death star
together so i think they're just bending over
backwards a little bit because they didn't
want to go through the trouble of bringing
hayden christensen back and hyping this up as
a big rematch without actually letting them
fight let them fight everybody post all your memes
but obviously it won't be their final rematch
because that's going to wind up being the death
star the same thing happened with obi-wan kenobi
in darth maul they had several different rematches
he tried to kill him several times it didn't stick
till much later in the timeline i'll explain
darth maul during the series too because there
have been rumors about him showing up but
they didn't talk about him during the panel
they were mostly trying to focus on the fan
service of bringing hayden christensen back
the whole reason for bringing him back though
because darth vader normally walks around with
his helmet on and speaks with james earl jones
voice so why would you need hayden christensen
well it's for scenes like this where you get to
see him without his helmet on when he's in his
regeneration chamber or his bacta tank or even
better when he gets his mass damaged in battle
in the vocoder the device that gives him that
trademark booming deep james earl jones voice gets
damaged and he speaks with normal anakin skywalker
voice inside the armor if you didn't watch star
wars rebels one of the best scenes during that
is ahsoka doing exactly that damaging his mask
during one of their fights and he starts to speak
as anakin skywalker inside the armor briefly
Ahsoka
anakin i won't leave you not
this time
then you will die
if they can come even close to a scene with that
level of pathos on the new obi-wan kenobi series
with hayden christensen darth vader versus obi-wan
i will be happy but the other footage that they
showed off at the panel that they didn't allow
online started with a scene of darth vader going
after some younglings being defended by another
jedi at a different temple because remember
during this period he's still going around the
galaxy hunting down the last of the jedi that
survived order 66 like Cal Kestis i will explain
where a lot of the other series during this part
of the timeline fit in with this obi-wan kenobi
series then there was another scene on tatooine
of this stingray-like creature floating above
slave workers just toiling away in the sand
ewan mcgregor had some voice over during this
part of the trailer where he says we start on
tatooine and go on a rollicking adventure then
they transitioned to a scene of a water planet
wasn't clear which planet it was there are a bunch
of armored soldiers firing on a bunch of many
armed sea creatures that was all probably just to
let you know that even though obi-wan kenobi spent
the last 10 years watching over luke skywalker on
tatooine between revenge of the sith in a new hope
he didn't spend all of his time on tatooine so the
adventure of the episodes will take him off planet
then we get a really awesome scene of darth vader
sitting on his throne in his castle on mustafar
communicating with a hologram of emperor
palpatine i'll talk more about his castle
in a second too because the series takes place
the year after his castle finished construction
then deborah chao and the producers ended
the trailer talking about how we definitely
see obi-wan kenobi and darth vader getting into
it again fighting each other showing the ewan
mcgregor version of obi-wan kenobi fighting darth
vader in his armor the scene was just meant to
evoke the imagery from their fight on mustafar
if you remember all the posters and the concept
art that they released before the movie came out
so just hyping up that kind of rematch with that
level of pathos but because this is 10 years after
revenge of the sith that means that luke skywalker
and leia are both 10 years old there were
rumors about them casting a young kid version of
luke but i don't know if they have plans to
do a young version of leia in a cameo scene
you have to remember that the series originally
was only going to be six episodes then they
chucked a bunch of those scripts rewrote the
series delayed it a little bit and turned it
into four episodes they didn't say how long the
episodes are going to be i'm assuming a little
bit longer than the mandalorian episodes the
mandalorian series is just a little bit different
with the way they put it together than what it
sounds like some of these other mini series are
going to be and ewan mcgregor did confirm earlier
that the obi-wan kenobi series is only meant to
be one season so it's just a true one-and-done
mini-series that doesn't mean that's the only
time that he'll ever show up in any future star
wars projects it just means that they don't have
plans for many many seasons of obi-wan kenobi
as for socatano during this part of the timeline
because this is happening right after she started
working with bail organa helping the rebellion out
she was very active in the outer rim when
the events of the obi-wan kenobi series will
be taking place so it's possible that she could
cameo in the series there was a rumor a long time
ago when they cast rosario dawson as ahsoka tano
that her contract included multiple appearances
on different disney plus series obviously during
this disney investor meeting they confirmed that
they're going to do a full-blown star wars ahsoka
tano mandalorian spin-off series but that's set
during the same time period as the mandalorian
which is five years after return of the jedi but
because rosario dawson looks exactly the same as
she did 10 15 even 20 years ago this is a picture
of her with hayden christensen they actually did
a movie together a long time ago which is why they
were together like this don't tempt me snips post
all your anakin skywalker ahsoka memes my hope is
is that at least at some point during one of these
live-action series they will do hayden christensen
in rosario dawson ahsoka live action scenes with
maybe flashback versions of them together when he
was still alive or in present day they could still
do anakin skywalker force ghost talking to ahsoka
so hopefully they'll find a way to do hayden
christensen in live-action ahsoka scenes in the
future ewan mcgregor said that the thing about the
series that was most exciting to him was that it
brought him back together with hayden christensen
hayden christensen kind of said the same thing
about you and mcgregor like i'm so happy that
i get to come back and do this and be with my
friend ewan mcgregor again they're also getting
paid a ton of money to do this when it comes to
darth maul in the series because they were hyping
up darth maul a long time ago i don't know if he's
as big of a villain as they originally intended
now that hayden christensen is coming back as
darth vader but the series takes place about a
year after the events of solo a star wars story
in this post-credits scene with darth maul showing
up being the leader of crimson dawn it sounds like
eventually they've been trying to get you and
mcgregor to come back and face off with darth
maul because ewan mcgregor said that originally
the obi-wan series was a movie that they were
going to do but then they just pivoted to the
disney plus series when those became a big thing
so at least expecting some darth maul cameos even
if he's not a major character during the series
but just in terms of other things happening
in the timeline right now this is a couple
years after the events of jedi fallen order
where darth vader almost catches calcus with
the jedi holocron with the names of all the
other jedi on it is about five years before
the events of star wars rebels and if you don't
know about darth vader's castle the whole thing
with darth vader's castle is the reason why it's
constructed on mustafar is because it's sort of
a ley line in the dark side of the force and he
learns that he can use it to construct a portal
to enter the afterlife and speak to padme so
a dark side acolyte helps him construct it
but then tries to betray him darth vader kills
him then winds up entering the portal that's
been finished in the dark side of the force gives
him all these visions he sees visions of padme he
sees visions of ahsoka tano before their rematch
and he sees luke skywalker without knowing that
it's luke skywalker he sees him as an adult but
i don't know if they're going to be using this on
the series because after that happened he got so
pissed off that he wound up destroying the portal
so he didn't get to use it again we saw a lot of
the exterior in the upper levels of the castle
during rogue one so just expect to see a little
bit more of that during the obi-wan kenobi series
they didn't say exactly when the release date's
going to be it'll be sometime between march 2022
and may 2022 but a really big reminder this week
my mandalorian season 2 episode 8 finale video is
going to post on friday just like normal i will be
doing mandalorian season 3 videos really soon too
my next video will probably be for the mandalorian
spin-off series the ahsoka tano trailer video
with the grand admiral thrawn stuff i'll explain
what's happening during that then there's a bunch
of marvel trailers there's the rogue one series
trailer and the details about all the other star
wars series if you have any big requests or big
questions about what's going on during the obi-wan
kenobi series or the mandalorian or anything
else just leave them in the comments below
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up it's
going to be really cool so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should see all
those videos pretty soon we'll have between two
and three star wars series per year in about four
marvel series so it's going to be pretty crazy for
the next couple of years but in the best possible
way they also confirmed the patty jenkins is doing
the next star wars movie that'll drop christmas
2023 it'll be rogue squadron she says it's going
to be based on a lot of the video games in
the books so if you read any of the classic
legends books they'll be pulling a lot of stuff
from there so it'll probably take place closer
to the events of the original trilogy while you
wait for everything click here for my brand new
mandalorian season 2 episode 7 video and click
here for that brand new loki trailer and all
the other marvel trailer videos thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!